the stillness of barra de Bunga belies
the activity happening hundreds of
meters below this giant of central
Iceland is awakening these earthquakes
are indicating that those magma beneath
the surface
if that magma reaches the surface and
actually comes out of the ground they're
nuts when we get an eruption it happened
in 2010 at a fer cocoon the eruption
closed European airspace for six days
stranding ten million passengers 100,000
flights were grounded costing Airlines
1.7 billion dollars there was a very
explosive eruption which was beneath a
glacier which sent a cloud of ash quite
high up into the atmosphere about eight
or nine kilometers that combined with
the fact that the jet stream was moving
the wind down from Iceland towards
Europe those two factors combined meant
that the ash was spread all throughout
Europe like I appeared yoku vara Bunga
lies under Iceland's largest glacier and
when lava hits an ice wall the result is
explosive steam and lots of ash the
glass-like particles can strip the metal
from jet wings and stop turbines by
melting and congealing inside of them
Airbus easyJet and Norwegian company in
okar Nagar have developed technology
that Fox fine ash plumes from a distance
this was the first test of the coast of
France last year one plane dumps a ton
of Icelandic ash into the atmosphere the
other uses infrared cameras to detect
the concentration of the ash giving
pilots enough time to fly around it it
called the avoid system and it works
meaning in the future easyJet won't
necessarily be grounded by an eruption
there's just one hitch the technology
isn't due to be fitted to the easyJet
fleet until 2015 so in the meantime it's
one of a handful of airlines watching
and waiting